[Musik]
meine lieben freunde und herzlich
willkommen wir heute zu einer neuen
episode minecraft mit luca staffel 2 die
vorne ist ja unsere sehr kleine aber
trotzdem sehr süße küche unserer hobbit
höhle hier vorne unser schlafgemach mit
dem süßen kamin mit dem margeriten und
dann hier vorne der storage ruhm also
der lagerraum oder auch der brauch dann
fehlt denen wir allerdings natürlich
erst bekommen können wenn wir dann
wirklich lohnen routen erhalten haben
die wir aber auch erst im netz besorgen
können heute soll es allerdings nicht um
die hobbit höhle gehen meine lieben
freunde sondern
ich habe ein komisches geräusch gehört
ist allerdings auch egal meine lieben
freunde denn heute wollen wir uns gar
nicht von ihnen etwas komischen ablenken
lassen von irgendwelchen geräuschen von
irgendwelchen monstern was auch immer
denn wir reparieren heute endlich unser
dorf dorthin
ich höre die ganze zeit zombies
irgendwie zunächst aber laufe ich mal
hier zu unseren kühen und paare noch mal
zwei von denen zwei weiß natürlich
gerade noch im inventar mehr habe ich
hier leider nicht drin ich musste die
ganze sache noch mal irgendwann alle
dann in die hobbits reinpacken doch
zuvor werde ich mich erstmal auf die
reparatur vorbereiten und dafür mein
inventar so aus lehrern und umräumen
dass sich genügend werkzeuge am start
aber zunächst einmal machen wir uns
nämlich eine schaufel dann noch eine
erneut ochs die hier ist ja schon fast
kaputt und dann wollte ich mir auch noch
eine neue spitzhacke machen ich glaube
dass wir diese drei utensilien auf jeden
fall gebrauchen können ich dann nur
nachts schlafen es ist noch nicht ganz
nacht von daher kann ich euch jetzt auch
erstmal ganz gut zeigen was überhaupt
heute der plan ist denn klar ich
repariere das dorf allerdings werden wir
zum beispiel das hier abtragen ich werde
hier vorne stufen hinsetzen so dass wir
einen vernünftigen weg haben den man
vernünftig lang laufen muss damit man
nicht die ganze zeit springen muss und
ihr seht ja auch schon das dorf ist
ziemlich lange hier sind überall
irgendwelche komischen sachen im weg wie
irgendwelche steinmauern und so weiter
und so fort die werden wir
selbstverständlich auch alle abreißen
nun es ist allerdings wirklich ziemlich
dunkel von daher sprint sind wir direkt
hier rein und gehen jetzt erst mal noch
in unserem ersten an das haus hier kurz
schlafen wir müssen auch demnächst
irgendwann die ganzen items rüberbringen
von diesem haus rüber in die höhle zuvor
kümmern wir uns jetzt allerdings wie
bereits gesagt um unser dorf deswegen
euch erstmal eine ganz kurze time
nützlich dass hier ein bisschen ebene
[Musik]
ich habe hier gerade alles so ein
bisschen saubergemacht allerdings habe
ich das gefühl dass meine tritscher
modifikation nicht mehr funktioniert und
das ist nicht gerade vorteilhaft bei
solchen großen bäumen von daher werde
ich dir jetzt einfach mal so dummen
stehen lassen und mich dann zur nächsten
folge hin darum kümmern dass diese
modifikation wieder funktioniert
allerdings habe ich bisher jetzt erstmal
hier den ganzen weg so ein bisschen
saubergemacht diese blöcke hierbei
das regt mich echt auf dass die hier in
aspen
wir müssen hier auf jeden fall demnächst
noch mehr bäume fällen
so freuen ich habe den weg jetzt mal
hier vorne so auslaufen lassen dann
läuft man hier so reinkommt hier dann in
das dorf rein und hier ist der weg dann
jetzt komplett gerade als sie befinden
sich keine lagerfeuer wer hier drauf die
stadt hier rum oder irgendwelche
steinernen mauern oder keine ahnung was
hier weiß ja nicht so ganz genau wie ich
das machen soll weil hier also eine
kurve lang läuft der hier muss
allerdings auf jeden fall auch noch weg
und hier beim rollen überlege ich mir ob
ich denn überhaupt mal komplett weg
mache weil er halt voll im weg rum steht
hier der mit hoffmann ich einfach so
einen platz lässt weil der brunnen ist
eigentlich todes unnötig da können wir
doch einfach abbauen jedoch werde ich
mich jetzt erst mal daran setzen mir
noch ein paar bruchstein stufen zu holen
so dass wir die dann gleich da vorne als
wege hinsetzen können ich befinde mich
jetzt allerdings auf der anderen seite
unseres dorfes und so habe ich hier den
weg komplett abgebaut und mit erde zu
gebaut so dass es hier so ein bisschen
verwirrt und der weg war sie hier vorne
endet deswegen wird er hier einmal so
rum gehen quasi zu dieser komischen
städte stein segen situationen hier und
diese ganzen sachen die kann ich auch
mal ganz kurz abbauen ich will zeit wenn
schon jetzt einmal richtig machen so das
halt alles perfekt aussieht also der
hier noch weg der weg und der weg und
hier auch nochmal kurz erde rein so dass
wir hier vorne dann quasi den weg so um
die ecke haben dann kann nicht dass hier
auch kurz abbauen bzw hier vorne auch
einfach erde drauf setzen dann denkt man
nämlich das geht hier einfach um die
ecke rum das ganze findet sich dann auch
hier vorne wieder war ich halt will dass
alles perfekt aussieht damit ich mich
halt auch wohl fühle ich weiß dass ich
davon das wird sich wahrscheinlich jeder
gute meinke spiele jetzt denken ich
profitiert davon nicht davon dass es
irgendwie jetzt schön aussieht hier um
die kurven da kann ich das vielleicht
auch sogar hier soll ein bisschen
irgendwie noch so lange bauen allerdings
finde ich dass es für mich einfach
schöner aussieht die blumen setzt jetzt
einfach mal hier in die ecke und dann
wissen wir hier vorne geht der weg lang
zu dieser städte hin und hier mit und an
den weg auch ausbauen und immer wenn es
ein bisschen höher gibt setzt sich dann
quasi steinstufen drauf damit es so ein
bisschen auch noch der
wiedererkennungswert hat von der ersten
staffel minecraft mit luca die gehen
allerdings alles schon schlafen deswegen
die ich auch mal ganz kurz kennen und
ein neuer tag ist auch schon angebrochen
freunde jetzt werde ich diesen wirklich
einfach mal noch hier vorne so ein
bisschen weiter laufen hier vorne dann
die stufen dran dann hier den weg wieder
so ein bisschen weiter so dass das ganze
in diesem bereich dann doch schon sehr
klein aus sieht die sache ist dann
allerdings dass sich halt nicht weiß wie
es ab hier weitermachen soll hier vorne
geht es natürlich erst mal hier runter
und hier vorne dann kann ich auch hier
den weg weiter laufen lassen und hier
sieht wirklich sehr cool aus der soll
hier natürlich nicht stehen allerdings
habe ich das und das wahrscheinlich
unterteilt schon gesehen dass hier auch
schon viel schöner gemacht mit der mit
dem berg hält das kann man vielleicht
auch bis hierhin sogar über ziehen dass
sie dann schon sehr sehr wild aus hier
mit dem berg die sache ist allerdings
dass ich halt wirklich nicht weiß wie
ich das und das kann nicht oft erstmal
hier vorne noch weiterziehen tatsächlich
das alles so ein bisschen künstlicher
schöner aussieht die sache ist
allerdings dass ich nicht weiß wie das
apropos
ich sage so häufig die sache ist
allerdings
wurden auch in die kommentare
geschrieben als ich muss echt mal
aufhören damit jedoch machen wir hier
jetzt erst mal ganz kurz weiter müssen
hier vorne alles erst mal so ein
bisschen wieder abbauen so dass es so
aussieht als ob der weg wirklich nen
oder langlauf wo der weg auch ist also
hier drei steinstufen hin dann hier
vorne mit der mit der schaufel wieder
darauf dass sie wieder abbauen die sache
ist nun allerdings dass wir uns jetzt um
den brunnen kümmern müssen und ich bin
wirklich der ansicht dass der brunnen
weg muss ich werde ihn jetzt erst mal
stehen lassen könnt ihr euch jetzt und
in die kommentare schreiben ob ihr denkt
der boden sollte hier bleiben oder
sollte abgebaut werden jetzt habe ich
allerdings auch keine erde mehr und
werde dementsprechend jetzt erst mal
ganz kurz aus unserem dorf hier raus
laufen irgendwo ein bisschen weiter weg
und leute treiben hier
ich will einfach nur erde abbauen
ich verfolge
dieser wald ist voller gefahren ein paar
sekunden später
vorleute projektiert
ich hab gesagt der wald ist voller
gefahren ich habe jetzt mal fast 26 erde
abgebaut die sache ist allerdings dass
unser dorf sicher so weit suchen das
hatte ich gar nicht mehr so richtig in
erinnerung das ist natürlich auch bis
nach vorne weiter geht mir geht es
allerdings heute erst mal um den
wichtigsten bereich und zwar ist das
unser bereich da hinten und vorne die
ausläufe die kommen sonst noch mal
jemand anders machen ich bin authentisch
auf eure kommentare angewiesen ob ihr
wollt dass der boden stehen bleibt oder
nicht schreibt mir gerne in die
kommentare
und dann gucken wir mal ob wir den boden
abreise in der nächsten folge oder
stehen lassen dass ihr euch allerdings
mal ganz kurz ab und erwägt geht dann
hier weiter das blöde ist nur das ist es
jetzt ab hier immer so ein bisschen
kniffliger wird auch mit den stufen weil
das von einem dreier weg dahin die zu
einem vierer weg wieder wird also hier
vorne geht es ja irgendwie lange ich
komme hier zwar so hoch allerdings geht
man hier so komisch irgendwie runter
deswegen werde ich den weg jetzt glaube
ich einfach hier so lange laufen lassen
so dass er quasi ab hier mit dreier
breite weiterhin hat okay meine schaufel
des gerade kaputt gegangen allerdings
dann hier vorne zu sonder vierer zwar
breite wieder wird in die richtung ich
mache mir auf jeden fall erstmal kurze
neue schaufelt und dann werde ich jetzt
auch erstmal hier vorne die bäume
abfällen ok guck mal die trikot paar
modifikationen funktioniert bei solchen
bäumen ich weiß allerdings nicht ob ich
irgendwas falsch gemacht habe bei den
anderen bäumen gerade oder ob es jetzt
irgendwie daran liegt dass das
tannenbäume waren weil hier funktioniert
alles perfekt das hier ist gerade nur
stehen geblieben weil wir vorne noch was
dran war aber das sollte jetzt auch mit
weg gehen ja perfekt und das ding hier
fällt sich auch komplett von allein also
ich weiß nicht was da hinten gerade
falsch gemacht habe allerdings ist der
bereiche jetzt erst mal komplett leer
ich weiß dass das süß und schön aus
sagen ich hab das auch so ein bisschen
an animal crossing erinnert die sache
ist allerdings dass ich erst mal alles
was ein trampelpfad ist weg machen
wollte und zwar zu erde nur wenige
minuten später ich habe keine ahnung ob
ich gerade falsch denke allerdings
könnte ich doch theoretisch einfach ein
wassereimer neben den hier drauf setzen
und das klappt nicht
dadurch sind jetzt nur meine
johannisbeeren kaputt gegangen die
setzen wir ganz kurz wieder hin und
jetzt müssen wir tatsächlich jeden
einzelnen blog hier mal ganz kurz eben
abbauen und jetzt setzen wir in jeden
einzelnen oktober nach hinten kann man
perfekt zu unserem eingang von der
hobbit höhe gucken jetzt setzen auf
jeden fall in jeder einzelne lücke hier
wieder einen erdloch ein so haben wir
jetzt auf jeden fall alles hier aus
gekleistert die sache ist dass das jetzt
natürlich wenn sich die ganze nördliche
angepasst haben und dann zu groß
geworden sind dann sieht das natürlich
ein bisschen
steril aussage ich meine sie dann auf
den kunstrasen fußballplatz
das wollen wir natürlich nicht
allerdings wollen wir das alles
natürlich von christian auf deine
symmetrie hat uns schön aussieht
deswegen werde ich das ganze hier jetzt
erst mal so ein bisschen anpassen an den
seiten und dann haben wir schlussendlich
hier einen platz wo man sagen kann hey
guck mal der sieht schön aus und er ist
vor allem frei von irgendwelchen bäumen
und hindernissen und irgendwelchen
monstern die das bauen können hier vorne
werde ich dennoch noch einmal ganz kurz
den weg abbauen und den oft durch erde
ersetzen so dass wir dann wirklich
irgendwie in der nächsten oder
übernächsten folge wenn ihr alles zu
gras verwandelt worden ist mal schauen
können wir den weg von hier über an dem
haus zu unserer hobbit würde nach da
ganz hinten führen können weil da soll
auf jeden fall was cooles irgendwie
stattfinden hier vorne sieht alles
perfekt aus hier sieht auch sehr schön
aus es fehlen nur noch so ein bisschen
die beleuchtung da kommen wir gleich zu
allerdings sind wir quasi mit dem weg
fertig bis zu dem brunnen hier vorne und
es macht jetzt wirklich keinen sinn für
mich hier weiter alles irgendwie schön
zu machen wenn ich nicht weiß ob der
brunnen hier weiter sein soll oder nicht
deswegen werde ich mich jetzt noch mal
ganz fix eben um die beleuchtung hier
kümmern dann nehmen wir ziemlich wieder
unsere eisen klumpen legen die hier im
kreis und packen die fackel in die mitte
so dass wir acht laternen bekommen und
ihr seht auch schon jugendliche ab acht
bruchsteinmauern und auch acht laternen
deswegen werde ich natürlich das ganze
genau so machen wie hier am eingang und
auch beispielsweise hier vorne mit den
laternen denn laternen sind einfach das
geilste leuchtmittel minecraft was es
gibt für mich ich werde erstmal hier
vorne einer hinsetzen an die ecke dass
wir nicht ganz schön dann haben wir das
hier auf jeden fall beleuchtet und hier
vorn haben wir zwar auch beleuchtung ich
finde allerdings dass hier an die ecke
auch so ein ding auf jeden fall hin muss
sagt dann können wir vorne auch noch
einen herzschlag hinsetzen und das ganze
so noch ein bisschen weiter hier
rumfahren um die ecke jetzt haben
allerdings nur hier vorne eine
beleuchtung und hier sieht alles sehr
dunkel aus ich muss allerdings erst mal
ganz gut schlafen gehen wir vorher noch
irgendwelche monster sparen habe ich
mich gar kein bock auf das jetzt
irgendwas an unserem schönen neuen wegen
in die luft fliegt also machen wir
direkt weiter in einem neuen tag und
schauen jetzt mal wo wir hier vorne
vielleicht noch ein bisschen
beleuchtungen setzen könnten ich finde
ich finde hier vorne sollte sich das
wiederfinden weil das ja auch hier vorne
ist so eine kleine laterne und dann
können wir das ganze auch hier vorne
machen wenn es hier untergeht bzw würde
ich vielleicht hier auch er hier oben
hin weiter zeigt dass unser eisen kohle
mit denen können wir theoretisch auch
mal ein bisschen heile der beschützer
unser dorf wie man so ein bisschen zack
das freut ihn auf jeden fall auch das
ist hier auf jeden fall auch so ein
bisschen ausgeleuchtet und die letzte
laterne setzen wir jetzt einfach mal
hier auf die ecke auch mit einem abstand
so jetzt weiß ja wie bereits gesagt
nicht was ich hier mit dem brunnen
machen soll habe allerdings noch drei
bruchsteinmauern und wir haben sogar
zwei eisen kohle fluggast
wahrscheinlich wahrscheinlich unser dorf
wirklich so groß ist also ich hab noch
nie so ein riesiges meint
ich habe noch nie so ein riesiges
minecraft darauf erlebt allein wenn man
sich mal auf der karte anschaut das ist
ja nur ein kleiner teil davon das ist ja
wirklich krass geht ja noch zu der seite
da vorne über und da hinten geht's ja
auch noch weiter ich werde jetzt
allerdings auf jeden fall meine
bruchsteinmauern nehmen und hier vorne
zum eingang auf jeden fall noch ein teil
hinsetzen sack dass wir einfach wissen
hier geht es los dann noch hier vorne
eine beleuchtung hier fehlen generell
noch die bruchstein stufen da setze ich
dann einfach mal hier beispielsweise
eine noch hin und dann können wir auch
hier vorne unsere buch steinstufen
dransetzen bamm bamm bamm und dann zum
beispiel hier vorne noch eine laterne
dann haben wir das auf jeden fall auch
fertig hier können jetzt natürlich auch
noch den mails beleuchtungen allerdings
weiß ich halt wie bereits gesagt noch
nicht so richtig wie ich das machen soll
mit dem weg ich war auch noch nie hinten
drin ich hab mir auch noch nie so
richtig die ganzen kiste hier angeschaut
das können wir eigentlich auch noch mal
ganz kurz vorm ende des heutigen videos
machen hier vorne waren wir glaube ich
schon dran genau da haben wir alle
studieren die sachen rausgenommen hier
fahren aber ich glaub ich noch was drin
gelassen genau die fichtenstämme süß
bären fichten schild und ein bisschen
kartoffeln bzw brote hier vorne haben
wir keine kiste drin das sieht auch sehr
cool aus als sessel somit den fichten
mit der fichten treppe hier vorne haben
wir eine kirche da wir einen
kartenhersteller und hier oben haben wir
nur brote papiere und leere karten drin
die können wir auf jeden fall auch
beschriften dann demnächst du geh jetzt
mal ganz kurz raus sie haben wir wieder
ein schleifstein hier haben die auch ne
kiste drin mit brot ich mag es einfach
mal ganz kurz mehr so einfach um baulast
hier ab so dass sich die kiste dann
einfach ganz easy hier wieder hinsetzen
kann so dann schauen wir noch mal ganz
groß was wir hier haben es wäre
natürlich krass wenn irgendwas heftiges
hier drin hätten die haben allerdings
überall nahezu nun die gleichen sachen
drin also tour auch wieder hin jetzt nur
noch eine werkbank hier haben wir noch
ein gebäude
auch mit einer kiste ich glaube wir
haben zwei trakte ich hab noch gar
keines markt in minecraft glaube ich
bekomme in diesem projekt allerdings
schaue ich jetzt mal was ich
wegschmeißen kann papier brauche ich
nicht und kürbiskerne bei euch auch
nicht richten setzlinge habe ich genug
weizen habe ich genug dann setze ich die
kiste für ihn wieder hierhin und dann
schauen wir noch mal ganz kurz eben
weiter was wir hier haben hier ist auch
eine kiste drin alter was geht denn ab
wie viele verschiedene sachen haben wir
denn hier am start im haus gegenüber
haben wie auch eine kiste darin befinden
sich eisen barren gold ein eisen ranisch
eisenach osmanische krass das geht denn
hier habe ich packe jetzt einfach eine
kornblume rhein und in chur wird um die
sachen immer so ein bisschen
auszutauschen gehen wir mal weiter in
den nächsten gebäude ich dass ich hier
noch nicht drin war klar wie viel eisen
und gold ja leid drin war hier ist eine
komplette rüstung am start ich lasse
jetzt einfach mal verrottetes fleisch
und tannen baumstämmen hier drin die
brauche ich ja wirklich nicht hier unten
haben wir auch noch im gebäude ich
glaube ich habe wirklich noch niendorf
in minecraft gesehen wo so viele kisten
am start waren hier ist keine kiste
keine ahnung warum jetzt keiner drin ist
allerdings geht es hier auch nicht
weiter das sieht wirklich setzen ruft ja
alles aus das müssen wir jetzt alles
noch ein bisschen schöner machen wir
haben sogar mein gott das hätten jetzt
gerade erst auch wir haben ja noch ein
zweites stockwerk bei unserer dorf
situation hier zwei stunden später brach
er war sogar obsidian drin und noch eine
neue eisen spitzhacke dass ich mir
dieses dorf nicht früher angeguckt habe
wir haben so viele sachen die wir hätten
gebrauchen können das jetzt allerdings
jetzt auch schon das letzte gebäude und
hier befindet sich kleine kiste mit drin
hier vorne war er auch nichts und da
hinten sind glaube ich auch keine
weiteren häuser mehr gewesen also dafür
ist die ausbeute auf unserem dorf habe
auf jeden fall erstmal genügend
rüstungen wir haben auch ein paar
smaragde gefunden um noch eisen und gold
und wir haben es geschafft dass europa
hier fordert ist sogar schon fast alles
zu groß geworden also können wir
demnächst irgendwann an geilen weg noch
über bauen da hinten runter und an der
stelle würde ich allerdings die heutige
episode von lukas erstmal auf beenden
wir haben so ein bisschen unser dorf
hier repariert schreibt mir wie bereits
gesagt ja nun den kommentare ob ich dem
boden stehen lassen soll und es tut mir
auch leid ich wollte man das in die
milch nicht nicht so viele entschuldigt
allerdings tut mir leid dass ich heute
mich nur um das dorf gekümmert haben
jetzt nicht wirklich auf kommentare
eingegangen oder wirklich voran gekommen
bin was das projekt ich besiege den
ender drachen angeht was soll ich in der
nächsten folge machen schreibt in die
kommentare wenn euch das wieder gefallen
hat dass keine tauben hoch unter dem
video abonniert main kanal und klickt
auf die glock wenn es euch gefallen hat
es tut mir sehr sehr leid dass ich ein
bisschen müde aussehe bin ich auch es
ist gerade halb zwölf und ich nehme das
video noch auf weil ich allein vor
produzieren wir sehen uns allerdings
morgen erstmal im neuen video wieder
aufnehmen kann
[Musik]